[THEME MUSIC]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and welcome
to episode number 127
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
My name is Mark Mandel.
And I'm here with my
colleague, Melanie Warrick.
How you doing, Melanie?
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm
doing good, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm doing well.
I'm doing well.
MELANIE WARRICK: Good.
So Mark, this week we
are going to be speaking
with a couple of our
colleagues, Liz and Seth,
who will help explore why SRE
versus DevOps is a thing--
and/or it's not a thing.
We'll get into that
in this interview.
MARK MANDEL: It's a big battle.
It's just fisticuffs and, like--
MELANIE WARRICK: Or is it?
MARK MANDEL: Just flying sparks.
MELANIE WARRICK: Are they
really secretly related?
MARK MANDEL: Basically
a Michael Bay movie.
It's fantastic.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah, exactly.
So before we get
into that, as always,
we go to our cool
things of the week.
And we have our
question of the week.
And this week's question is--
MARK MANDEL: I'm a researcher--
I'm not actually, but if I was--
I'm a researcher at a
regionally-accredited academic
institution.
And I need some
compute resources.
Does Google Cloud
have any programs
that help me out with this?
MELANIE WARRICK: That's
a great question.
We will get to that.
But before we do,
as always, we're
going to start with the
cool things of the week.
And as some of you may know,
Google I/O was last week.
And so the actual
videos from the event
are already up on YouTube.
And we'll include that
link in our show notes,
so you should check it out.
You can see all the
cool announcements.
You can watch the assistant
talk to, I think, a hairdresser.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK:
All the fun stuff.
MARK MANDEL: All the fun stuff.
And definitely also a bunch of
sessions from our teammates.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Lots of developer
advocates from Google Cloud
doing some amazing stuff.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Yes, definitely.
MARK MANDEL: And
speaking of I/O--
excellent segue, if
I do say so myself.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: At I/O, our
friends over at Firebase
released a whole
bunch of new stuff
that's super, super cool,
all worth checking out.
Quick overview-- one
of the big flagship
things I think that I'm very
excited about is ML Kit.
ML Kit is a series
of ML APIs that
can both be run on
device or in the cloud,
depending on the functionality.
So there's five production-ready
ones available now--
text recognition, face
detection, barcode scanning,
image labeling, and
landmark recognition.
And there's more coming.
They also announced improved
performance monitoring as well.
MELANIE WARRICK: And I believe
they're expanding Firebase test
labs to iOS.
MARK MANDEL: Yep, they're
doing that as well, which
I'm also super excited about.
There's better analytics.
And really, there's
just more stuff coming.
So definitely
check all that out.
And as we said
before, there's links
in the show notes to all the I/O
sessions where they would add
stuff all about that, as well.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
The other thing we wanted
to mention for this week
is that Jeff Dean is
the new head of AI.
So he's heading up that
effort inside Google,
which is a little bit different,
but still similar to what he's
been doing around Google Brain.
Congratulations to Jeff.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, finally, for cool
things of the week,
we want to mention that we are
introducing Cloud Memory Store.
This is something you
can play with right now.
It's a fully-managed in-memory
datastore service for Redis.
So this is pretty cool.
It's your standard
Google Cloud fare
in that you can go
in to the console,
fire up a Redis instance.
It has integration
into Stackdriver,
on demand pricing, and
a lot more features
that are definitely coming up.
We totally want you to
come in and play with it.
They'll have links
in the show notes
to the Google Group
and the issue tracker.
And you can totally
play with it now.
We want to hear what
your experiences are
like playing with
our Redis offering,
and just hope you all enjoy.
MELANIE WARRICK: You should all
message Mark directly and tell
him exactly how you feel.
MARK MANDEL: DMs
are open on Twitter.
You can totally message me.
I will tell you to go
send it to other places.
But if you really
feel the need, please.
You can.
You totally can.
MELANIE WARRICK: There you go.
All right.
So Mark, I think it's time to
go speak with Liz and Seth.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
Let the battle begin.
So I am very excited to
have both Liz Fong-Jones,
staff site reliability engineer
at Google, and Seth Vargo,
staff developer
advocate at Google,
to settle once and for
all what's better--
SRE or DevOps?
How are you all
both doing today?
Liz, how are you doing?
LIZ FONG-JONES: Hi,
I'm doing great.
It's a pleasure to be here.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent,
thank you so much.
Seth, how you doing?
SETH VARGO: Great, great.
Thanks, Mark and Melanie,
for having me here today.
MARK MANDEL: So before
the thunderdome begins,
why don't you tell us a
little bit about who you are
and what you do at Google?
Liz, why don't you go first?
LIZ FONG-JONES: Sure.
So I work as a site reliability
engineer on the Customer
Reliability Engineering team,
where we teach Google Cloud
customers how to
better operate and run
their systems so that they
work great in the cloud.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
And you, Seth?
SETH VARGO: Cool.
I'm Seth.
I'm a developer
advocate here at Google.
And I work with customers,
potential customers, and users,
particularly around
the DevOps community
and making sure
that Google Cloud is
one of the best clouds in which
to practice and illustrate
DevOps.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
Well, so, can you tell
us a little bit more
about what exactly is DevOps
and what exactly is SRE?
How are they different?
How are they connected?
SETH VARGO: DevOps is
a cultural movement
that was started around
2009, officially.
But there's a lot of
recorded incidents
of DevOps occurring all the
way back to 2003 and 2004.
It really refers
to this condition
that happens in many
organizations, small and large,
that operators and developers
have this divide where
developers are responsible for
writing code and accelerating
the business.
And operators are responsible
for keeping that code
running and keeping
the business stable.
Inevitably, what
would happen was
that developers would
write this code,
and they would throw it
over the metaphorical wall
to the operations team and
say, keep this running.
Keep my Java app, keep my Ruby
app, keep my Python app up
and running.
But operators would have
little or no understanding
of the language
it was written in,
the requirements
of the application,
or the business goals
of the application.
So inevitably, they were
fighting an uphill battle
continuously, where
they were being
asked to monitor
and maintain systems
which they had no input in.
And they had no ability to push
back on the developers and say,
you know, hey, this
code isn't so great,
or this isn't going
to work at scale.
And this challenge
ultimately led
to this idea of
DevOps, which is, what
if we eliminate that barrier?
What if we force or encourage
developers and operators
to work together in a way
such that the operators bring
their experience in
running systems at scale
and distributed systems.
And developers bring
their experience
of coding and
algorithms together so
that we can build better systems
and more reliable systems.
And that's really
the crux of DevOps.
There's kind of some
sub-pillars that come with that.
So there's these kind
of six or seven things,
like reduce organizational
silos is a big one in DevOps.
We want to just
reduce the bureaucracy
and these artificial walls
that exist between groups.
Accepting failure as
normal is another big one.
One of the big
challenges, and one
of the reasons there was such
a divide between developers
and operators, is that if at
any point something went wrong,
it was all about
blaming someone.
Well, who was at fault?
Who can we blame for this?
Whose budget do we
deduct this from?
The third was that
we very quickly
realized that these huge,
waterfall-like developments
where we ship a million
lines of code at once
was not a great way to be
able to recover from failure.
So first we accept failure.
But then one of the ways
to reduce that failure
is to just do
incremental changes.
So instead of shipping these
huge, brand new features,
let's just ship one
small thing at a time,
leveraging things like
tooling and automation
to make sure that we're not
spending all of our time
touching systems but
are instead automating
things and measurement.
Another challenge
with this, and part
of the reason that the
wall can be broken down,
is that when we start
measuring things,
we start talking quantitatively
instead of qualitatively.
It's much easier to
have a conversation.
So those are just a few
of the DevOps pillars.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: So Liz, SRE--
what's that all about?
LIZ FONG-JONES: The
practice of SRE at Google
started in the early
2000s, in response
to many of the same pressures
that Seth is describing
of having systems not really be
resilient and not be scalable
when you're trying to build
and run some of the largest
software systems in existence.
So Google engineers
realized that they
needed to apply the techniques
of software development
to operations, that you
couldn't run operations
as a separate function.
But instead, that
you needed to have
people with a combination of
operation skills and software
development skills working
together to run and design
these systems.
So SRE is a combination
of several things in that
it's both a job title that
a bunch of humans at Google
have-- such as myself--
and it's also a mindset
and a organization.
And it's a set of
engineering approaches
that we use to run better
production systems.
We tend to focus a lot on
measuring service reliability
and identifying, what
engineering changes do
we need to make to systems in
order to make sure that they're
more scalable and maintainable?
And this can mean everything
from doing measurement
of our systems to make sure that
they're appropriately reliable,
to developing automation,
to being intimately involved
in the design and
figuring out kind
of how do we simplify systems.
So it started at
Google originally
but spread to many,
many different companies
beyond Google.
But in the end, it kind of
solves the same problems
that Seth identified of
having a wall between software
development and operations not
being a desirable thing at all.
MARK MANDEL: It
sounds like there's
a lot of overlap
between SRE and DevOps.
Should I be doing SRE?
Should I be doing DevOps?
Which one's better?
Which one wins?
LIZ FONG-JONES:
It's all contextual.
It depends on what's
most likely to work
in your own organization.
It definitely is the case that
because of the fact that there
are so many different
commonalities between SRE
and DevOps, you can
almost think of DevOps
as being an abstract
class or interface,
and the SRE class being
a concrete implementation
of the DevOps principles.
So, for instance, Seth
talked about the idea
of breaking down silos and
trying to use common tooling.
And that's something that
definitely SREs feel and SREs
do, in that we have
the same set of tooling
that we use on product
development and software
engineering teams and SRE teams.
We do measurement.
We measure the level
of service reliability.
We have service-level
objectives, which we'll maybe
talk about in a little bit.
We have the notion of using
automation and tooling to solve
problems whenever possible.
That's kind of the building
software part of SRE
that I talked about earlier.
So in all these
various ways, SRE
is a very concrete and
specific and prescriptive
way of accomplishing the
goals that DevOps also
sets out to solve.
MELANIE WARRICK: Would you
ever call yourself DevOps?
LIZ FONG-JONES: That is a
very complicated and fraught
question at Google
because of the fact
that Google came up with
SRE at about the same time
that other people were coming up
with DevOps outside of Google.
I definitely would
say that when we're
talking about SRE techniques
and SRE best practices,
that practitioners of DevOps
will find that a lot of them
apply to them.
And conversely, we learn a
lot from the DevOps movement.
There are a lot of
things that we take back
in from the DevOps movement.
MELANIE WARRICK: So I
guess that you could also
say there are multiple
ways of implementing
DevOps outside of just SRE.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Yes and no.
I think SRE is the
only one that actually
has a brand associated with it.
So I'll give you an example.
We take one of those pillars,
like accepting accidents
and failures as normal.
One of the things that many
people who implement DevOps do
is called postmortems, which is
after an outage or an incident,
we collect all of the data.
And we have a meeting--
it might be internal.
It might be external--
where we analyze everything.
And we have next
steps to, how do
we prevent this in the future?
Or if it happens in the future,
how do we reduce the impact?
In the SRE program,
that's a key pillar.
It's called out.
And in many other
organizations' DevOps programs,
it's a key pillar
that's called out.
But actually in no part of the
DevOps manifesto does it say,
you must practice postmortems.
So I think there are many
ways to implement DevOps.
I think SRE is the
only one that I'm
aware of that actually kind of
has a name and its own brand
associated with it.
MELANIE WARRICK:
What kind of tools
are your favorite tools to
use in your respective spaces
of DevOps and SRE?
SETH VARGO: You know, DevOps
is a cultural movement.
It's not a technology movement.
So everyone kind of
has their own things
that they like to use.
For me, I like tools that
practice infrastructure as code
and increase collaboration.
So tools like Terraform,
tools like Chef and Puppet
and Ansible and Salt that let
us take these abstract concepts
like infrastructure--
cloud providers
like Google Cloud, systems
like a Debian system--
and capture the
code and the process
in a not only
repeatable manner--
so we can talk about automation.
But what I like is that we
can focus on collaboration.
We capture this as code.
And now we can put it in a
pull request and a source
repository.
And we can collaborate
on the changes.
We can have our
teammates coming in.
And it's one thing to
have someone standing
over your shoulder in a
terminal saying, yeah,
that command looks
good, and another thing
to be able to actually
comment on a pull request
on something like GitHub and
say, yeah, this change is good.
So I tend to like tools that
obviously solve a technology
problem, but they do it in
a way that is collaborative
and encourages collaboration.
So I think that's one of the key
pillars of the DevOps movement.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice, and Liz?
LIZ FONG-JONES: I think
that the key to SRE
is not necessarily using
one specific set of tools,
but instead saying, you
know, you have to use a tool.
Pick one to accomplish this
particular set of objectives.
For instance, I agree
with Seth that you
have to have some
kind of mechanism
of having your config as
code-- having it checked in,
having it repeatable,
having it reproducible,
having it be usable
by automation.
And I don't care which
particular tool you use.
And in fact, most of the
tools that I used in my career
at Google have been tools that
are proprietary to Google.
And that's fine.
You know, there are plenty
of equally good tools
available outside of
Google that accomplish
the same goals for people
that don't work at Google.
Another thing that I'd
recommend, for instance,
is you have to use something
to monitor your systems.
I don't care whether
it's Prometheus,
or whether it's Datadog, or
whether it's Stackdriver.
I just care that you pick
a tool and stick to it.
It's better than muddling
around in the dark.
SETH VARGO: Yeah, and I
think to double down on that,
it's not just important
that you pick one.
In a large organization, it's
important that there's buy in.
You can't have the
team over there
using Datadog and the team
over there using Prometheus.
That might work
at a small scale.
But these systems all need
to talk to each other.
So you need a centralized
source for things
like monitoring and
alerting, or else it's
going to be very difficult
to actually visualize
how these systems are
operating and functioning
at a very high level.
MELANIE WARRICK: Which plays
into your whole fundamental
around collaboration
to begin with, right?
SETH VARGO: Right.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, and it sounds
like also the culture of SRE
and DevOps within
your organization
needs to be-- like,
it's a culture.
It's a company culture.
SETH VARGO: Yes, definitely.
LIZ FONG-JONES:
Yeah, absolutely.
And I think that ties into
another element of needing
institutional support, right?
Someone needs to provide a
career path for your SREs
or for your people
practicing DevOps.
You can't really say, you know,
this is my one DevOps engineer.
This is my one SRE.
And they're just going to
do magical stuff, right?
You have to have a
community of practice.
You have to have a mechanism
of supporting them.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Liz, you said something earlier.
And you said you were
going to allude to it.
So I'll pull it up now.
You were talking about
sort of SLIs, SLOs, SLAs.
We've talked about them
previously a little bit
on the podcast.
But people who haven't
listened to previous episodes--
what are these things?
Why do we care about them?
LIZ FONG-JONES: Sure.
So I'm happy to break that down.
So we're talking about
three key terms--
a Service Level
Indicator, or SLI,
a Service Level Objective,
or SLO, and a Service Level
Agreement, or SLA.
And a service level indicator
is the basic building block
of that.
It's a mechanism of deciding, is
your service available enough?
Is it healthy enough that
in this instantaneous moment
you would consider it good?
And then over time,
you can aggregate that
into a overall service
level objective that says,
x percent of the time, my
service level indicators
should be satisfied.
So you might decide
it's OK for my service
to be down for 10 minutes
out of every month.
Or it's OK for my service
to be down 20 minutes
out of every month, or two
hours out of every month.
So you have to decide on
what that threshold is.
And that percentage is a
service level objective.
And then a service
level agreement
is a promise that you make to
someone that has consequences.
For instance, you might
agree to remediate the issue
and provide a post-mortem.
Or you might agree to provide
money back to a customer
if you fail to meet your
service level agreement.
So to break down things
a little bit further,
a service level
indicator specifically
tends to be some kind of
key performance metric.
And then it's subject to some
kind of a windowing function
and subject to a threshold.
For instance, I might
say my key metric
is how fast does it take to load
the home page of Google.com?
And then I might say, OK,
I want the 95th percentile
of that latency distribution.
And I want to make sure
that that's always less
than, say, 150 milliseconds.
So then that generates,
at any moment in time,
a yes or no value.
Is it good enough or not?
And then I might say, I aim to
have that satisfied, let's say,
99.99% of the time.
And then that gives
me an idea as to
is my service healthy enough?
Do I have room in
order to experiment?
Do I have room in order
to do deployments?
Do I have room in order to
do more experimental things?
Or do I need to slow down?
Do I need to say,
hey, wait a second.
We need to focus on stability
for the next few months
rather than on deploying as
many new features as possible?
So that's kind of leading
into the concept of an error
budget of the difference between
one and your service level
objective.
And then how much
of that is left
to spend based on how
available you've been
over the past number of months?
SETH VARGO: So Liz, all
that makes a lot of sense.
But how do you deal with a
situation where you have--
we haven't mentioned
it yet, but we
know that they're called error
budgets, which is basically
once that SLO is exhausted,
the remaining time
is an error budget.
How do you just prevent those
teams from just ignoring it?
How do the SREs have power
within the organization
to push back on the developers
so that they're not just
ignoring these
agreed-upon criteria?
LIZ FONG-JONES: It's a manner of
collaboration that the service
level objective arises--
the target itself comes
from a collaboration
between product management SRE
and the product development
software engineering
organization.
And we are empowered
to push back.
And we are empowered to
escalate, if needed, to say,
we're endangering the
service level objective.
We need to cut back.
Or we need to do
engineering changes,
and to get people
to agree on that.
And in the end,
if someone insists
on doing super risky things
and breaking the error budget,
then we have the right to pull
SREs off of a project and say,
you know what?
You can go and hire
more software engineers
to replace the SREs
that are stepping away.
But SREs are scarce
and valuable.
And we think that there are
more projects waiting in line
to have SRE support that are
willing to stick to their error
budgets and SLOs.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Wow, that's great
that you guys have that
type of empowerment.
LIZ FONG-JONES: We
know that it's not
universal across all
sizes of organizations.
I think the key thing that
anyone listening to this
should take away is
the idea that you
need to have some kind
of executive sponsor
that's willing to
decide, here's where
I'm going to allocate SREs.
Here's what's acceptable
for them or not.
And if you don't
have that person,
your SREs are probably
going to eventually leave
if the error budgets
keep on getting broken,
and they keep getting
paged and feel that they
can't do anything about it.
MELANIE WARRICK: Are there
anything else that you'd say
is crucial to make SRE
a success for companies?
LIZ FONG-JONES: I
think the other thing
that's essential to making
SREs successful, besides having
executive sponsorship and
having agreed upon service level
objectives, is the idea of
measuring how much time you're
spending doing
operational work, or toil,
as we call it-- the idea
that we should measure
how much of our time do
we spend that's doing work
to stay running in place?
Stuff like doing
manual deployments.
Stuff like responding
to tickets.
Stuff like making sure that the
system is fixed once it breaks.
Versus what are we doing
to make the service more
sustainable and scalable
in the long term?
What are our long-term projects?
So that idea that we should have
a budget of how much time we
spend on toil and keep that
below half the time that we
have in the day, I think that's
kind of a key practice of SRE
that prevents it from degrading
into having a operations
team running around
not really empowered
to do engineering work.
That's the thing
that we use to guide,
is are we spending
less than half
of our time doing that
manual work or not?
MELANIE WARRICK:
Seth, I know you
were talking before about
how much collaboration
is a priority from a
DevOps perspective.
And I assume you've got
similar, like-- executive buy-in
as being something that's
a factor of success.
Are there any other factors
of successes that you think
are very crucial for
DevOps to be successful?
SETH VARGO: Yeah,
I mean, I think
automation, which
we kind of already
touched on a little bit, is one
of the key factors of DevOps.
It's this idea that
people get burned out
as they continuously don't
bring value to the organization.
And this is traditionally
one of the challenges
with operations in general
is that if you're not
bringing value to
the organization,
it's really hard to
retain employees.
Because they don't feel like
the work that they're doing
benefits the company.
And SRE, it's Site
Reliability Engineering.
They're engineers at
the end of the day.
And DevOps-- typically
folks practicing DevOps
have engineering backgrounds,
like in software or computer
science.
So they want to actually
be engineering, right?
And they might not
want to be building
self-balancing red black trees.
But at the same
time, they don't want
to be running the
tail command all day.
So finding that balance
between the toil
and touching the
system manually,
versus building these really
great systems, whether it's
a custom homegrown CI/CD
for delivering things,
or custom alerting and
monitoring solution,
or just integrating
automation and orchestration
across the entire cluster
to be able to bring value
to the daily lives.
MARK MANDEL: Actually,
to that point,
you're talking a lot
about automation.
Are you factoring in
stuff like SLOs or SLAs
or something similar in
the DevOps space that
would translate through to SRE?
Or how does those two things--
do they work together?
SETH VARGO: So there's
nothing specifically in kind
of the DevOps manifesto
that says how to measure
things, other than measure.
So this is one of
the big differences,
and kind of why we say, like,
class SRE implements DevOps,
is the DevOps says you
should measure stuff.
And it doesn't tell
you whether you
should be using the metric
system or the English system.
It doesn't tell you you
should be using Prometheus
or Stackdriver or Datadog.
So it's up to
individual organizations
to make that decision,
whereas the SRE discipline
is very much along the
lines of leveraging tools
like Stackdriver, et cetera.
LIZ FONG-JONES: And I think that
that's an area where we've seen
a little bit of divergence
between DevOps and SRE that
we're hoping to kind of mend--
this idea of, do
we measure how many
deploys per day that we do?
What is the metric that we use
to measure customer happiness?
And that's why I think that
it's important for everyone
to start adopting
service level objectives,
because a good service
objective is focused on,
what does the customer
actually want to achieve?
Can they achieve what they want?
Rather than kind of focusing
on, how many percent
Pingdom success do I have?
Or, am I shipping 1,000
deploys a day, but all of them
are breaking the
build, or all of them
are making customers unhappy?
We have to agree
across our industry
on what makes customers happy.
Are we converging
on the right number?
And is it something that
is sustainable for us?
SETH VARGO: Yeah, and
I think to rephrase
that in a slightly different
way is that the DevOps movement
evolved out of making developers
and operators happier,
whereas the SRE
movement evolved out
of increasing customer
happiness by building
more reliable systems.
And what you find is that--
Liz, I don't know if you agree
or disagree with me here--
but the practices are
actually pretty similar.
But that's why you'll tend
to see the DevOps movement
focus on things like
deploys per day,
whereas the SRE teams
will focus more on,
like, latency and
ping time and render
time of the actual interactions
of customers or users.
MARK MANDEL: Do you agree?
LIZ FONG-JONES:
Yeah, I totally do.
MELANIE WARRICK: Seth, you
briefly talked about CI/CD.
Is CI/CD required
to do DevOps in SRE?
SETH VARGO: Again, yes and no.
It's not specifically part
of the DevOps manifesto.
But automation is
a key pillar here.
And having these continuous
integration continuous delivery
services such that I can push
some code-- whether that code
is to provision infrastructure
or an application--
and I can test it in
an automated fashion.
While that's happening, I
can be doing other work.
I can bring other value to the
system or the organization.
And at the same time,
what you'll find
is that CI/CD is closely
related to collaboration.
Having the ability to perform
continuous integration
and continuous
delivery ultimately
leads to higher collaboration.
So that's why it's part
of the DevOps movement,
but it's not specifically
required to do DevOps.
MARK MANDEL: Actually,
now that I think about it,
in previous times we've
talked about SRE culture,
we haven't really talked
about continuous integration
and development.
But that seems like something
that would potentially reduce,
like, basically errors
and things going wrong.
Liz, where does that fit in?
LIZ FONG-JONES:
So similarly, SRE
doesn't say you
have to do CI/CD.
But we do rigorous risk
analysis to figure out
what risk factors might prevent
us from meeting our service
level objectives.
And it winds up being the
case that if you are manually
doing deploys, and if you're
manually doing builds,
you're going to be delivering
defective software more often.
You're going to be spending
a lot of time rolling back
in case of outages.
And that adds up and eats
into your error budget
and eventually leads
to unhappy customers.
So we practice CI and
CD as a consequence
of wanting to fulfill
our error budgets,
and as a consequence of wanting
to keep the amount of manual
toil that we do under control.
In SRE, we do error
budgets and toil budgets.
And we also have baked
into our systems,
because of a lot of our
developer productivity
tooling, the notion of having
reproducible builds already
done for us, that the
product development software
engineers already come
to us with these things.
And they typically
need help with,
how do we roll this out
in a scalable matter?
How do we detect
failures earlier?
So it's kind of working on more
of the advanced aspects of CD
where we really shine.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
On a slightly
different note, how
do you collaborate
with security teams?
Or what are best practices
for SRE or DevOps
to integrate into and
communicate with security?
SETH VARGO: There's
actually this sub-movement
of DevOps called DevSecOps,
the Sec obviously standing
for Security there
in the middle.
There's also Dev Marketing
Ops and-- you can put any word
in the middle that you'd like.
And it's this idea that
security, just like operations,
shouldn't be its own department
that does its own thing.
Instead, it should be
embedded with these teams who
are working closely.
It's much easier to
fix a software problem,
whether it's security
or operations,
closer to the
codebase than once it
reaches this arbitrary
governing body that
says, yes, this is secure.
No, this is not.
And what you'll also find
is that having someone
embedded on the team who
is security-minded or
security-focused can
often have more context
going into a security
review than just handling
thousands of lines of code
over to some third party team.
And not only does
it take them time
to understand the code and
the goal of the system,
but then also they have
to review it for security.
Obviously security is
something paramount to Google.
It's something that
runs in our blood.
So we have dedicated
security teams here.
But we also have people
who are constantly
thinking about security
from a software engineering
perspective embedded
on different teams.
And the DevSecOps
kind of culture
is really the same thing.
Let's not just break down the
barriers between developers
and operators.
Let's break down the barriers
between developers, operators,
and security teams,
because they're also
traditionally viewed as
kind of this place where
dreams go to die, for
lack of a better word.
There's two places
where dreams go to die--
MELANIE WARRICK: I like this.
MARK MANDEL: --the security
team and the legal team.
And if we can get those
teams to collaborate and work
closely from the beginning,
with the software
engineers and the operators,
it improves the likelihood
of the success of the
project over time.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
Liz, did you want
to add anything around SRE?
LIZ FONG-JONES: SRE and
security really go hand-in-hand.
In particular, SREs are
empowered to shut off a service
if it poses a grave
security risk to Google.
Like, that's kind of--
SETH VARGO: Big red button?
LIZ FONG-JONES: Yeah, you
have to put the users first.
And protecting our users is the
first priority that we have,
even above the number of nines.
It's better for Google to
be down than for Google
to be posing a security
risk to our users.
Furthermore, a lot of
SREs move back and forth
between SRE and
security and privacy.
The mindsets are
very closely aligned,
because SREs are
constructively pessimists.
And that's the case with
security and privacy teams,
as well--
that we wanted to help
you do the right thing.
And that we're often
prepared to think
of what can possibly go wrong?
How can we guard against that?
Rather than say, what
can possibly go wrong?
And therefore you can't launch.
No, that's not what we say.
I think another
interesting nuance
there is that the approach
of SRE teams at Google
is closely aligned with
privacy and security,
with regard to building
frameworks that do
the right thing out of the box.
That's a thing that we've
started doing in the past six
or seven years at Google to
really focus the development
efforts in SRE
upon not just what
do we do in one
individual product,
but how do we make sure
that everything bakes
in the right default, whether it
be for reliability or security
or privacy?
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
Thanks, Liz.
So one other question
I have for you
both is, what do you
enjoy most about SRE?
LIZ FONG-JONES: I think the
thing I like the most about SRE
is that it's really
a cross-disciplinary
collaborative team, that
we have a whole variety
of different SRE teams all up
and down the stack at Google
that all work together every
single day to make sure
that Google is
appropriately reliable.
And also that we have
so many different skill
sets on those teams,
whether people
come from systems engineering
or systems administration
backgrounds, or traditional
software engineering computer
science backgrounds,
or humanities
or physics backgrounds.
Like, we all work
together as a team.
And we solve these really
challenging problems
and make Google
run at that scale.
And that's what really
makes me love my job.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
then Seth, what do you
enjoy most about DevOps?
SETH VARGO: I mean,
basically the same thing.
The DevOps community is, like,
this incredibly diverse group
of people, ranging from
folks with backgrounds
in theater and arts and
software and math and physics.
And being able to not only
interact with those people,
but see how their experiences
and their backgrounds
bring different
solutions to mind--
like, that collaborative
nature is truly inspiring
to see the different
ways that people think,
and the different ways they
arrive at conclusions--
sometimes the same,
sometimes different--
and how that can lead
to ultimately making
better software and
making customers happier.
MARK MANDEL: And if people want
to learn more about DevOps,
do you have any particular
places you like to send people?
SETH VARGO: Sure,
you can all call me.
My phone number is--
I'm just kidding.
So there's quite a few
places to learn about DevOps.
There's obviously, like,
Wikipedia and stuff.
DevOps is a little bit weird,
because there is no one
true definition of DevOps.
It's something that
a couple companies
have tried to grab onto and
claim it as their own brand.
But ultimately, it's
an organic movement
started by a community.
So everyone does have kind of
their own slight definition
or slight lens which
they see through DevOps.
So I actually
recommend people look
at what DevOps is
not before they start
looking at what DevOps is.
And there's a lot of
really good articles
out on the internet that
will explicitly say,
like, this is not DevOps.
A quick search of the
most popular search engine
will show you, what is DevOps?
Look for things like myths of
DevOps, or what is not DevOps?
And you'll start to get a
better idea of what it is
and how you can start.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
We'll put some in
the show notes.
Liz, if people want to
get involved with SRE
or learn more about SRE, where
do you think they should go?
LIZ FONG-JONES: The resources
that we have for SRE
revolve primarily around
the SRE book, which
is published by O'Reilly, and
authored by a number of Google
engineers.
There's also two
upcoming books about SRE
also being published
by O'Reilly--
namely, the "Site Reliability
Workbook" and "Seeking SRE."
One of those is written
and compiled by Google.
The other one is
written and compiled
by a friend of mine who
now works at Microsoft.
And we also have the
Google.com/SRE website,
in which you can go read more.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
And I was going
say, I know we also
have your video series that
touches a little bit on SRE
and DevOps--
that has season 1.
And anything else
that you guys wanted
to talk about in
terms of SRE/DevOps
that we haven't covered?
SETH VARGO: You know,
Liz and I are always
looking for new and exciting
things to talk about.
So if any of you have ideas
for a potential season
2 for the DevOps and SRE
video series, please give us a
shout out on Twitter.
Our handles will be
on the show notes.
MARK MANDEL: Liz, anything
else from your end?
LIZ FONG-JONES: And there's
also the Google Cloud Platform
blog, where members of my
team, the customer reliability
engineering team, publish best
practices and other things
that we've learned from working
with large GCP customers.
MELANIE WARRICK: Fantastic.
MARK MANDEL: Well, thank
you to both of you,
Liz, Seth, for joining us
today, telling us about--
I think everyone is a
winner with DevOps and SRE.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
LIZ FONG-JONES: All right.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks so
much to Liz and Seth
for joining us for
the podcast today.
I think that potentially
solves which wins--
SRE versus DevOps.
Well, everyone wins.
I feel like everyone wins.
MELANIE WARRICK: Everyone wins.
MARK MANDEL: Everyone wins.
Awesome.
So let's move forward to
the question of the week.
So the situation is
that, in theory, I'm
a researcher at a
regionally accredited
academic institution.
And in an ideal
world, I would need
to be able to do some research.
And I need some computer
resources to do that.
Is there a way where
Google Cloud can give me
some possible
credits or anything
like that to make my
life a little bit easier?
[TINKLING CHIMES]
MELANIE WARRICK: Why, yes, Mark.
There is.
I'm glad you asked.
And the reason why there
is is because we've just
announced a new credits program
for researchers specifically.
Which, for our
listeners out there
who might have heard us
talk about this in the past,
there's been a
couple of programs
we've talked about for
education and for other areas.
But this is
specifically targeted
for researchers, and researchers
who, as Mark was saying,
are from accredited
academic institutions
for certain countries.
It's limited right now
to certain countries.
And there's a list on the site.
The amount of the
award is $5,000 US.
And there's an
application process.
And it's an ongoing--
it's a rolling
application process.
So it's not like a
specific time frame.
I know that I regularly
get this question
from people I talk to who
are out there in the research
communities.
You know, the biggest need
they have right now is
compute resources.
So this program is
specifically targeted for them
and to help expand.
And it's interesting, too,
because on the link that we'll
share in the show notes,
they talk about some
of the different programs
that it's supporting
and just a significant
amount of petabytes of data.
They're using it at--
Ryan Abernathy, who's
Assistant Professor of Earth
and Environmental Sciences.
The Ocean and Climate Physics
at the Lamont-Doherty Earth
Observatory at
Columbia University
is using this through
an NSF partnership.
And with his team they're
developing open source platform
to manage the complex data
sets of climate science.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And this platform
called Pangeo can run Earth
systems modeling simulations
on petabytes of high-resolution
three-dimensional data.
MARK MANDEL: That's cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's very cool.
It's cool to solve
science problems.
OK, Mark, are you
going to go anywhere
in the next couple of weeks,
next couple of months?
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
Well, I'm actually not going
anywhere like traveling--
MELANIE WARRICK: Are
you speaking somewhere?
MARK MANDEL: I will be at the
monthly SF Game Developers
community meet up
on the 30th of May.
I'm going to do a presentation
called, "You Can't Just
Add More Servers."
MELANIE WARRICK: Sometimes
you really just can't.
MARK MANDEL: Sometimes
we just can't.
MELANIE WARRICK:
So that's great.
Well, I will be,
this week, speaking
at the Understanding Risk forum
in Mexico City on the 17th.
So if you're there,
come find me and say hi.
And outside of that, I
think we'll both be mostly
around San Francisco.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
Mark, one other thing
we should touch on
before we head out.
How will people get
in touch with us
if they want to get
in touch with us?
MARK MANDEL: So if they
want to reach us on email,
that's hello@gcppodcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: If they
want to reach us on Twitter,
it's @GCPpodcast.
MARK MANDEL: If they want
to reach us on Reddit,
it's /r/GCPPodcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: Google+,
it's +GCPPodcast.
MARK MANDEL: If they want
to find us on the internet,
it's gcppodcast.com.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And on Slack, you
can request an invite to the
Google Cloud Slack community
and join the #podcast channel.
MARK MANDEL: That's
at bit.ly/gcp/slack.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, Melanie, thank you
so much for joining me
for yet another
week on the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thank you, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: And thank
you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
[THEME MUSIC]